ist ruhig da bist du bescheuert herzlich
kommt sondern wieder leute dieses video
ist eine fortsetzung von dem video was
ich vor drei tagen hochgeladen habe habe
ich vor drei tagen den ersten teil einer
hilfen folge angeschaut die definitiv
auf der etwas absurderen seite des
lebens ist eigentlich muss man nicht
viel mehr als den namen sagen so die
folge heißt mein freund verlässt mich
weil ich im rollstuhl sitze
ihr könnt euch denken leute diese folge
macht überhaupt keinen sinn begann damit
dass irgend so ein pärchen an so einer
club eingangstür steht vor dem nachtclub
am hellichten tag und dann kommen die
nicht rein weil sie im rollstuhl sitzen
dann sagt ihr freund einfach weil er
einmal mit ihr nicht gekommen ist
jo ich mache schluss eine frau im
rollstuhl habe ich schon mal gar nicht
nötig also sucht ihn ein freund dafür
dass man als kleiner hinweis für die die
erst verpflichteten damit wird sagen wir
da gar nicht darum dann möchte ich sie
gefragt sind über ein abo freund folgten
auf insgesamt 1 gezockt und jetzt sieht
man los
[Musik]
guckt man sich ok berichtet dass wir
stehen geblieben also ja also es ist
wieder herrlich der tag die drei sind
gerade aus dem klub rausgekommen
am hellichten tag ob ich meine soll ja
aber nachts feiern gehen mir sowas von
2018 müssen eigentlich bin ehrlich
tatsächlich trotzdem ein bisschen
schockiert davon bin ich schon viel von
rtl2 gesehen habe dass sie sich nicht
mehr die mühe machen also diese aus dem
klub raus oder reingeht s10 hat etwa
nachts zu drehen dass es am helllichten
tag gedreht welcher mensch kommt am
helllichten tag aus dem clubhaus
afterhour jetzt mal ausgenommen antwort
keine
also man muss dazu sagen leute diese
person die man hier im hintergrund
gerade sieht also dieser typ der so
krasse aufgepumpt ist das ist der
ex-freund von der dem rollstuhl sitzt
das ist der typ der weil er einmal nicht
in den club gekommen ist mit seiner
freundin die im rollstuhl sitzt dann
sofort mit ihr schluss gemacht hat also
wir können schon mal aufschließen
ein sehr korrekter typ mal schauen was
dazu sagen okay ja heute also sehen
recht eindeutig dass der typ
möglicherweise kein allzu korrekter
mensch hat gerade mit seiner freundin
schluss gemacht weil sie nach einem
unfall im rollstuhl sitzt was macht als
nächstes schnapp dir einfach mal vor die
nase das taxi weg an der stelle muss man
sich einfach in aller deutlichkeit noch
mal sagen
zweimal haben die frau im rollstuhl mit
vier sitzen lassen
ich kann auch die ängste
[Gelächter]
ich will eigentlich fluchen weil wir es
aber was für einen pass rat alter ja
sorry aber sitzplatz hat sie ja schon
mal dann kann sie erwarten also wir
sehen ob die leute es ist ein sehr
hilfreicher bericht wir können mal
kurzen blick in der beschreibung werfen
da ist die rede von einer ratgeberserie
die jungen menschen wertvolle ratschläge
zur krisenbewältigung gibt heute ist
natürlich die klassische und alltäglich
und für uns alle schon bekannte und da
gewesene situation da dass der eigene
partner mit einem schluss gemacht hat
weil man wegen dem unfall im rollstuhl
sitzt und dann einem noch vor der nase
das taxi wegschnappen will helfen mir
vielen dank nochmal dass er für diese
wirklich sehr weit verbreitete situation
ratschläge gibt
also ich weiß ja nicht leute also die
sache ist dieses mädchen wasser im
rollstuhl sitzt es hat am anfang dieser
folge schon den wunsch geäußert dass ich
jetzt an ihrem ex freund rächen will
weil er so unfreundlich war
dementsprechend sie genießt dies
wahrscheinlich auch gerade ein bisschen
so inhalt so dass tatsächlich zustande
muss man jetzt jemanden der wegen dem
unfall im rollstuhl sitzt das taxi
wegschnappen
das leben kann so einfach sein wenn man
es drauf hat und ich hab's definitiv
drauf die wette anregung heute ist jetzt
schon mit seiner pannen attali zusammen
zu sein
ja auf jeden fall gute logik von ihr so
ich meine also er hat jetzt den wohl
grund genug bis zu bereuen dass sie sich
von ihr getrennt hat mal ganz davon
abgesehen dass es natürlich übel sehr
hoch war
aber ist das grund genug um eine
trennung von der person zu bereuen dass
man ein taxi nicht bekommen hat und zwei
minuten länger warten muss da ist schon
krass ist schon krass
ich wünsche dir gesagt nicht warum ist
das ist ein großer deal gut dann bereits
gewehr nicht wirklich erwartet dass wir
all zu viele dinge dieser folge sind
machen die kommen wir nach wie vor am
helllichten tag mittags aus ihrem
clubhaus und vielleicht auch nochmals
hinweise also für mich ist es besonders
schlimm den ganzen unsinn zu sehen weil
einfach dieser klub vorne dass die sogar
türen burg in köln das sind vier minuten
von mir zu fuß als es direkt um die ecke
bei mir jetzt schon bei hilf mir so orte
zu sehen mit dem nicht so eng verbunden
bin ist schon heftig aber janka film des
taxis weggefahren
wie wir alle wissen gibt es in köln
einer stadt mit einer million einwohnern
nur ein taxi und bis das mal wieder
zurückkommt kann man lange warten ist so
aufgeregt
so etwas sagt dann zaubert doch mal
wieder ok oh taxi übrigens habe ich
andere schon richtig gut am haken nach
er hat mir gestern so was von auf die
möpse gstaad also andré ist ihr ex
freund andré ist der bright gepumpt oder
gar team mit der sonneberger stand und
wir alle wissen leute selina hier auf
der linken seite die blonde die im
rollstuhl sitzt ganz ehrlich die hat
andré ist und komplett die irgend so
dass andere jetzt nicht einfach weg
zieht aus köln ist mir persönlich
unerklärlich main hat einfach seine
krasse wir uns so ausspricht hat einfach
sein taxi nicht bekommen muss einfach
zwei minuten länger warten so rum diary
wird ja auch bald verlassen
die zickerei hat doch keinen bock also
ich habe mich wirklich leute ob die bei
rtl2 so vorgaben bekommen dass die story
so keinen sinn machen darf wisst was ich
meine
als ich meine man hat ja immer so
natürlich man hat diese
laienschauspieler so nennt man die also
schauspieler die eigentlich eine
schauspieler sind sondern etwas anderes
machen und die machen halt per se schon
die folge nicht so gut aber ich habe
mich wirklich auf rtl2 so story schreibt
die keinen sinn machen weil also soll
gewusst wir sind jetzt diese andrea
dieser tätowierte ist jetzt seit wieviel
ein zwei tagen mit seiner neuen freundin
zusammen welcher normale mensch macht
nach zwei tagen mit der neuen freunde
direkt wieder schluss allianz ist das
muss man auch noch dazu sagen der typ
mit dem anzug und anscheinend so manchen
dies mit den braunen haaren hier auf der
linken seite hat man in dieser szene
gesehen dass es mehr als freundschaft
ist woran macht man das fest von
andererseits sollte also es ist wirklich
nicht so dass ich hohe erwartungen an
die story habe aber gehen die schon
wieder feiern
bro literally die letzte szene war
gerade wie sie aus dem klub rausgegangen
sind und die nächste szene ist dass es
sich wieder fertig machen fürs feiern
muss sagte sinn
ich habe gerade echt keine zeit mir
darüber gedanken zu machen
ich muss mein ex fertig machen und das
ist echt ein fulltime job sehr
lobenswert leute von der ratgeber serie
hilf mir das hier noch mal ganz klar und
perfekt und auf den punkt genau gezeigt
wie man sich verhalten sollte wenn
jemand mit einem schluss machte
natürlich sollte man nicht mit seinem
leben weitermachen sich auf sich selbst
konzentrieren und irgendwie schauen dass
man wieder glücklich wird und sich ein
paar versuchen ein
maßnahme nummer eins und das
allerwichtigste
nachdem mit einem schluss gemacht wurde
ist rache
[Musik]
deuce
apropos alter ja er hat jetzt ihr geld
abgesteppt jetzt zum allerersten mal in
dieser folge beim dritten mal haben sich
dann tatsächlich geschafft die clubszene
in der nacht zu drehen
ich habe mir kann sie wieder gehen
ok folgen der typ trägt sie am anfang
noch so was dann passiert ist mir
eingefallen das jedoch wieder gehen kann
das ist ja wissen gerne also ihr habt
die chance vermisse mein körper okay
leute schauen mir geht es jetzt mit dem
tätowierten die wieder in die ganz
andere richtung ohne wird sollte dieser
tätertyp ist einfach es ist echt die
härte sondern auch mit seiner frau die
im rollstuhl sitzt schluss macht
irgendein anderer an und sobald seine ex
freundin wieder aus dem rollstuhl raus
zu sein
die kleine ausnahme eifersüchtig vertrag
wenn ich die zeit vertreiben
bei dir was du bist teil und
unkompliziert so einfach kann es einfach
aufhören ganz einfach mit zu reden ist
beendet
zwischen uns gar nicht egal was ist mit
diesen menschen los alter es heuer also
ich weiß nicht ich sehe nicht den
ratgeber sinn oder charakter von dieser
sendung so dieses mädchen hat der
rechten seite die sowjets celina hat
einfach so eine richtig krasse
erniedrigung so erfahren müssen dass ich
meine leute zu ihr freund hat mit ihr
schluss gemacht einfach nur weil sie
jetzt im rollstuhl sitzt für ein paar
monate oder so danach kann sie ja wieder
laufen und nur weil er gesagt hatte
mit der komme ich den kopf rein macht
einfach schluss was macht sie schnappt
ihm einmal ein taxi vor der nase weg
danach wieder ankommt und wieder an sie
ran machen will ist ja okay also wir
können gerne wieder so was haben so ist
nicht so als ob du mich mega gekränkt
hätte macht nur mit der schluss- und
dann geht's wieder weiter
da bist du bescheuert
was soll das also soll heute aber ich
muss wirklich mal die frage stellen wo
ist bei dieser folge von einer
ratgeberserie der rat wo ist der rat
welchen hilfreichen tipp kriegen junge
leute aus dieser sendung für ihr leben
er weißt du was wenn irgendjemand nicht
so richtig fertig macht ok und er
reduziert sich einfach so krass auf
deinen körper mit auf eine tankkarte
irgendwas sich verändert ist er sofort
zum ort gar keinen bock mehr auf denen
kannst du dieses forschen okay die
situation ja was soll ich da machen
kommen direkt wieder mit ihm zusammen
das ist besser für dich ja vielen dank
nochmal eine rtl2 für diesen
wundervollen rat ich bin sicher er hat
einiges für ihr leben gelernt solltet
ihr überraschender weise der meinung
sein dass diese folge hier komplett
hängen geblieben ist und ihr eure wut
darüber kundtun möchte dann schreibt das
gerne in die kommentare
täglich vorgeschlagen dass wir können
etwas was mir ganz gut erklärte das war
so weit von uns